he's a first-ballot hall-of-famer in
Chicago Illinois for tonight's big game
bears-packers he's Brian or like oh how
are you Brian I'm doing good rich a some
crazy new isn't that though then I just
break that to you if you know about
I haven't played I don't pay to I don't
follow that stuff I don't care I talk
until you tell me I don't really pay
attention that's not so isn't it though
I mean it's crazy
I don't understand what just just saw
play football I agree and I think I
think the piece he doesn't put up with
anything does he he seems like a very
straightforward guy like this way or
that and there's no there's no
in-between with him I wouldn't think
which is why it was kind of surprising
that he would make as his first big move
as a general manager the acquisition of
Antonio Brown Brian but if you get a
chance to make that move I think you
have to make it he's a great player you
know when he's on the field he's a great
player just yeah I mean after what
happened to Pittsburgh and now this is
going on Copeland hang and you know
someone else if they do cut him or
whatever someone else take a chance on
it you know that he's took it of a
talent for someone not to try and sign I
may look or the Patriots because they
can fix everybody well I think Antonio
would probably say if you got him in a
quiet moment aside that he is that's all
he's trying to do is show up and play
football he just didn't show up to the
training camp because he was dealing
with his helmet and that he didn't show
up to the walkthrough because of X Y & Z
why do you need me for a walkthrough for
a preseason game I'm not even playing
just stick me out there Monday night you
could see what I'm doing just don't
bother me with this fine letter stuff
that's probably the way he's thinking
Brian you can think that way you want to
that's not how it works you know
lovey-lovey find us if you missed it
didn't matter hurry word you got
walkthroughs any kind of meeting any
kind you you were fined and if you
missed the practice that was a big deal
that was a big sign it no no little
fifty-four thousands a lot of money but
it would have been much bigger than that
I would think pick it off easy and you
know what about the sense though that
you treat players differently there
because of their talent level though
Brian what about that sense why I never
got that why I played because our coach
didn't do that I don't think that's
happening
Elson right now either from what I could
read I don't see do we lose Brian her
just punishing him for what for what he
did Brian Urlacher here on the Rich
Eisen show okay what did it mean Brian
back in the day when lovey took to the
podium when he became the bears coach so
talking about the Packers first what did
that mean I lost you for a second about
the Packers yes when lovie smith took to
the podium when he was named coach the
bears and started off saying first
things first we're gonna beat the
Packers what did that mean eat the
Packers that meant a lot you know
because up to that point they had our
number I think we were two and six
against in my first four years maybe
even one in seven so when he came in
there and he didn't say where mr. ball
went division he said we're going to
beat the Packers that's our number one
goal and it was good for us to hear that
but you know more important the fans
heard that and that's you know I think
it resonated really really well with
them and and then they didn't just say
we're out there and did it you know he
was one of the first coaches that
actually got a chance to finally beat
them and and we did there for a little
while we had their number then Aaron
came around and things changed I heard
your difference in your voice right
there when you said things changed yes
they did in the wrong persons favor they
changed very quickly in their favor so I
had Favre on in the first hour I asked
him this question I'll ask it of you
first things first what was it like
standing back where you were
and seeing number four on the other side
what was that was that for you
Brian was first it was nerve-racking
because that's my guy like I was a kid I
was a Cowboys fan so I fight they fight
the Packers every single year cuz they
both wanted division quite a bit but I
was a Brett Favre guy I loved the way he
played I loved the way took chances he
threw his body out there I didn't care
just reckless abandon and then he had to
play against them my first couple years
I was kind of it kind of an all at first
because you know that's pretty far off
so I was like wow I'm planning it's
Brett Favre tonight the first game I
played him I got a sack was really cool
but I got a they got a pick the next
year so it's just it was cool you know
to play against one of the greatest on
top three four quarterbacks of all time
was really cool early in my career well
I asked him that question about you and
he said that you were smart and that he
had to all basically had to account for
you called you a great player I mean he
had nothing but the greatest of us
for you brothers very nice coming from
you know what was fun about him is he
loved to play you could see that and you
could see lit on the field
you know timeouts he was always yapping
not like talking trash just oh man I got
a faster days blah blah blah shot me a
buck last night let the hotel when I
slice to you know Gator in the head just
talking stupid stuff in between uh
between breaks or stuff he was just a
funny guy do you get you can see how
much he loved to play football and I
also asked him he's a kid from
Mississippi your your kid from New
Mexico Brian and and asked him if there
was anybody that had to sit him down and
tell him about the significance of the
bears-packers when they when he arrived
there what about you know one I think
you you and we played them fifty Iraqi
year we were always more going up their
backs you beat them in Lambo but I
didn't need to be sat down you
understand the first week the first day
of the week with all the media that the
new media that comes in just for that
game it's crazy and the local so close
and proximity to them that you don't
need someone to tell you what what this
game means or what it comes down to you
do all the records out that week that's
for dang sure they don't really matter
would you play against uh and how about
you later in your career did you ever
impart that to some young players in
your locker room we didn't have to not
rich like we had to you know it's
because you talked about during straight
and what love he was there and he didn't
just say it from day one I mean at the
first interview he appreciate the whole
time we were there
there's always beat Green Bank beat
Green Bay so he pretty shed his whole
career but he was there so we didn't
need to tell the young guys hey this is
important and now that they're more
important in the other games but they
have a little bit more meaning to our
fans into our organization than some of
the other games Brian Urlacher Hall of
Famer here on the Rich Eisen show was
did you ever get a call from anybody
saying are you are you done for sure
anybody try to get you back out dr.
Brian no I did not you know I uh you
know what's funny is if coach marinelli
went to Dallas and he's still there
obviously he coached at the D line I
think it's first year it was DC and I
actually reached out to him when Shawn
Lee went down I was like hey coach this
is you're out there I was like if you
need a guy I'm your guy son we felt that
Coach Morelli I was like hey if you need
a guy you know I could uh I could run
your defense for you but it obviously it
didn't work out I was too damn old and
he was too smart to just timing
I don't think Bears fans can
seeing you at the star on the side of
your head Brian I'll be very honest you
know you know as a kid I grew I said I
should hope as a as a Cowboys fan so
that in my mind I'm like lot of cowboys
actually just like all right now from
the sunset you know going to play for
them close to home blah blah blah I'm
glad it didn't work out so you didn't
call balichek since obviously as you
said the Patriots fix everybody didn't
even call Bill Nighy Monica along with
everybody too well over there too good I
didn't I was like I was a troublemaker
the locker room so I probably wouldn't
fit in Brian Urlacher Hall of Famer here
in the Rich Eisen show a couple more
minutes left with you so uh what's
tonight were you watching the game
tonight were you watching I'm actually
going to the game I know we're excited
yeah I'm gonna miss the Cask xbox
watching the game from her point of view
okay excited any other former Bears
gonna be in that suite you know what I
don't know not not that I know of anyone
that's going to I know there's gonna be
a lot of my ex or former teammates are
gonna be a at the game but I'm not sure
where they're all sitting spoke to him
about that are there any former
teammates yours that you're gonna seek
out because you really want to see him
you haven't seen him in a while I'm sure
I'll see a bunch of pregame well
actually I guess Grant Park is a huge
there's a huge NFL thing going on down
there right now so where my wife and I
are going there right now it's a custom
festivities there and then we're gonna
hang out for a little bit there and then
go over to the game early so we can see
some of the pregame so I never got to go
to the pregame stuff at the Bears games
I'm always running late from dinner or
snacks or something
so I never get to go watch all the
pregame stuff over to get the area to
watch that tonight all right I am aware
of somebody who is gonna be in the
stadium tonight that maybe you should
seek out that Forte they're all working
they're gonna be there all those great
guys okay no you're missing one as well
yesterday one of the guys asked me he
said he was we know we're talking about
Jay Cutler they said he was going as
well so I mean maybe my guy you know
maybe you catch up
them right maybe just I'm not sure we'll
be in the same month same area I'm not
sure where he's hitting or where I'll be
sitting so I I'm not sure rich well if
you run into him just let me know
because as you know I'm kind of obsessed
by this relationship yeah I know you are
hey I'll definitely reach right out to
you if I if I haven't and we'll be the
first guy to do an interview on the spot
or something come on every room or
something like that pretty fresh oh I'm
a uniting people together but you knew
that I do well yeah we're here to take a
take a selfie do you know how what that
would do on social media if you and Jay
Cutler took a selfie media guys I don't
know but you're sociable though you're
like one of the greatest guys I've ever
come across a room yeah no I like
talking to people and stuff like that
but I'm not like social media I'm not
I'm not a real big picture taker stuff
like that
mm but thank you that's a good idea
though it's just that you know Brian I'm
just trying to make you better that's
all ice what I said to Favre he said he
was playing in front nine he said he
sucked on the front nine he would talk
to me at the turn I told him he was
gonna shoot low on the back nine cuz
that's what happens I make people better
back I guess we will get that
information out and ER is going to
immediate yeah he's got a report back
and see us at least you you know he's
got a hold for the back man I have no
hope for a theophany mom dude I know
it's going to be too crappy nines and I
get to go home and pout okay well enjoy
enjoy the game Brian enjoy tonight thank
you I hope you see everybody you want to
see and and connect with connect with
everybody from your past that you're
you're so fond of so I just want you to
make sure you have a good time than I
thanks for the good thoughts Rach I
really appreciate your best Brian
Urlacher we have a tremendous rest of
your show that's Brian alert for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app